es un rayo de esperanza para el julian
assange el máximo tribunal de reino
unido autorizó al australiano apelar la
sentencia de la corte suprema que falló
a favor de su extradición a eeuu en
diciembre una victoria para el
informático y sus allegados
saben lo que ha ocurrido en el tribunal
es precisamente lo que queríamos que
ocurriera el máximo tribunal certificó
que hemos planteado una cuestión del
derecho de importancia pública y tiene
motivos para conceder la apelación ahora
falta ver si la corte suprema decide
acoger ese recurso
de opción el anuncio es el último giro
en la lucha de assange por evitar ser
juzgado en eeuu donde se le imputan
hasta 18 cargos de espionaje por
publicar documentos clase ubicarlos en
su conocida plataforma wikileaks algo
que podría costarle décadas de prisión
los abogados de assange han advertido en
repetidas ocasiones que una extradición
sería fatídica para su salud mental y
que temen que las condiciones en una un
estadounidense sean muy duras para la
activista a pesar de las garantías del
ejecutivo de baile
todos los que han examinado esas
supuestas garantías las han condenado y
juzgado como si no valiera ni el papel
en el que están escritas
el gobierno de estadounidense ya ha
prometido esas garantías antes y las ha
roto sesión 6 organizaciones de derechos
humanos advierten que su traslado podría
poner en peligro la libertad de prensa
en el mundo ahora en medio del debate
sobre si assange es un informático o un
periodista la corte suprema deberá
decidir si acepta o no el recurso